morning to you it's reported the
government is determined to push ahead
with vaccines for 12 to 15 year olds
despite advisers recommending against it
the jcvi the government's vaccination
advisors concluded that the benefit to
children's health is only marginal now
the uk's four chief medical officers
will consider further evidence before
handing over to ministers for that final
decision our political correspondent
kate mccann reports
we're used to seeing people queuing at
vaccine centers like this but could we
soon be seeing children waiting in line
too
the scientists who advise the government
on vaccinations don't think so but
ministers have asked medical experts to
look again
their focus will be on the impact to
wider society which some believe is the
priority
the jcbi considers the risk benefit of
the vaccine alone for that age group
alone the broader societal and broader
community aspects of the question i
think will be this will be considered by
by
the chief medical officer and the health
minister an appropriate decision stable
but the joint committee on vaccines and
immunization which only looked at health
benefits so the picture is very finely
balanced and that benefits to the rest
of society are highly uncertain given
our current understanding of the impact
of vaccination on transmission in the
short and medium term
others argue that long covered is a good
enough reason alone to be vaccinatingly
young
eleven thousand children
uh have had long covert for more than a
year and that's not trivial having
eleven thousand children develop
resistant disease for more than a year
and you can talk about the hypothetical
future harms of vaccines very few
vaccines have long-term effects shown
after three to four months and
myocarditis which is the only
complication that has been found so far
is very very rare at a rate of about 30
to 40 per million and happens in the
first week so there's no reason to think
that their long-term effects we know
there are long-term effects from covet
though and we know they can be severe in
many children so the direct benefit to
children far outweighs the risk
alongside the row over science there are
big moral questions too which parents
will have to grapple with
we need to start vaccinating the rest of
the world
i think that's more important at the
moment i just feel like everyone should
be vaccinated
i just feel like it's the best way
forward that's it yeah i'm fully
vaccinated i feel safer if i had
children i'd want them to be vaccinated
the decision is now in the hands of
scientists who are expected to report
back next week but will parents watching
the divide growing over whether
vaccinating children is right or wrong
be willing to support it when it comes
kate mccann sky news
let's have a look at the latest coveted
figures for you and there have been a
further 42 076 new cases in the last 24
hours
more than
121 people have died after contracting
covert in the last 24-hour period that
takes a number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test to 133
041.
look at the vaccines then and more than
40 000 first doses have been given
nearly a hundred and twenty thousand
second doses more than 43 million people
are now fully vaccinated
now the number of people killed by
hurricane now store mida has reached at
least 64. it's officially the fifth
strongest storm to ever hit the us
mainland it brought up to 10 inches of
rain with most places in its track
getting up to twice the average month's
rainfall in just one night and so far
estimates put the total cost of the
damage at 50 billion dollars and rising
our u.s correspondent mark stone sent
this report from manville in new jersey
which suffered the worst death toll
it's taken 24 hours for the floods
around manville to recede
at first glance a place like this
doesn't look too bad but it's deceptive
the mud is the only sign that all this
was metres under water physically
financially psychologically this extreme
weather is testing communities and
families
like the shahs their home and their
business destroyed
that's my uh limo business car that's my
limo business you can see it has the new
york plates on it and i was i couldn't
do anything about it because it was
almost like four feet water by the
course
we're just stuck in strand here we
couldn't able to see that window
yesterday
that that window up there yeah the water
was that high you go inside you'll see
four feet water inside we're standing
like 15 feet down right now
after you
it's young murid shah who wants to show
us inside it's like old trash everywhere
you can see the sofas
everything the family only moved here
eight months ago and now it's all gone
as you'd expect the small town spirit
here is strong i feel that we have a
responsibility as a
as a community and one
is better than the other no one can be
better than others if you see another
person being affected so i just realized
that walmart was close so i stopped in
edison and
fill up the
the car with water our family friend the
mother and her daughter house completely
to the roof submerge step standing wow
everything i mean between all the
explosions i mean i even felt my own
house shake explosions yeah there was a
couple house explosions
sure enough around the corner two of a
number of houses that were leveled the
floods caused electric and gas
explosions thankfully everyone here
evacuated
this small new jersey community was
right underneath ida as it swept north
dumping record rains as it went
every house block off the block was
flooded
up the road is macaro's ironworks
family run for two generations a fencing
company that's now ruined the whole
business everybody we got over 80
employees over here you know
so
i don't know just devastated is anything
salvageable no just memories that's it
that's all you're gonna save now
inside it's obvious that they will have
to start again
everybody bought it's open five out of
six and a family five people work over
you
but as you say you built it up once you
can do it again we can do again that's
right again
we're gonna do it again yeah i wish you
good luck okay thank you
back outside the shah's house muid
wanted the final word
i feel very sad for my grandparents i
really wish i can buy them a new one but
i don't have any money mark stone sky
news in new jersey
some flu vaccinations will have to be
postponed because of delays in vaccine
supplies to gps saquirus the majority
supplier of influenza vaccines in the uk
says that because of unforeseen delays
with road freight it's hacked to tell
all gp practices of a delay to their
scheduled deliveries between at one and
two weeks it means flu vaccination
clinics will have to be replanned
huge queues built up at immigration at
heathrow as a result of covid checks at
customs with staff needing to hand out
refreshments as people waited the home
office said protecting the safety and
health of the public is its priority
though it is trying to roll out more
egates
president biden has signed an executive
order directing the fbi to declassify
documents relating to the 9 11 terrorist
attacks it's seen as a supportive
gesture towards victims families who've
long sought the records in the hope of
implement implicating the saudi
government
there was celebratory gunfire in kabul
overnight as the taliban claimed to have
captured the last area of afghanistan
not under military militant control
panshir valley north of kabul has been
the centre of opposition to the taliban
and has been fiercely contested over the
last week but the national resistance
front who are defending the region have
denied they've lost control
several people were reported killed by
that celebratory gunfire
new zealand's prime minister jacinda
adern has called for a period of
national unity in the aftermath of a
mass stabbing at a supermarket in
auckland
seven people were injured three of them
critical
we have it within our powers to ensure
that the actions of an individual do not
create a knock-on of hate judgment in
vitriol
i know new zealand you'll be kind please
wrap your arms around all of our victims
those of yesterday and those of the past
well more details have emerged about the
attacker let's get the latest now from
logan church of tvn said
we now know the man arrived in new
zealand from sri lanka on a student visa
in 2011. he was 22 years old and at the
time there was no indication that he had
any violent ideas but that changed in
2016 following a series of alarming
social media posts which were
immediately red flagged by the
authorities here he was eventually
arrested at auckland international
airports thought to be bound for syria
and over the following years faced a
myriad of charges and spent three years
in custody but it got to the point where
there was no legal option to keep him in
prison any longer and in july he was
released
then the police monitoring began
round-the-clock 24-hour surveillance
officers were shadowing him as he went
on his normal shop here at the countdown
shopping as normal for 10 minutes before
pulling a knife from the shelf and
starting his attack
seven people in total were caught up in
this three are in a critical condition
in hospital
almost nine in ten teachers say they've
experienced a death in their school
community a figure worsened by the
pandemic yet only a small number of them
have had bereavement training to help
them help their pupils
ashna huranak reports
19 roses have been planted in this
memorial garden over the past year
each one marks the death of a parent or
carer of a child at this school
all died with covert 19
but how do you support children through
such grief when you're their teacher
the child's not expecting you to have
all the answers what they expect is for
you to continue
being you
sometimes they want just the academic
um
lessons to continue but on other
occasions they just want you to be able
to
smile at them say the right word or
show them or inform them who they can
speak to
it's a skill set not everyone is armed
with child bereavement training is
optional for teachers many are relying
upon intuition rather than instruction
but plenty believe the latter is a must
bereavement is part of life when we work
with children we work with the whole
person and we are living in a society
now where things are changing all the
time and schools increasingly are having
to become
um
i suppose a holistic support service for
for children and for parents was there a
particular aspect that you wanted to
learn first
it's the lessons that mary's university
in west london believes is worth having
these trainee teachers are a week into
the new term but soon we'll learn how to
support children through loss
they're looking at things around
the language we use to talk about death
people are incredibly awkward about
talking about death and don't know what
to say so therefore don't say anything
which actually is probably the worst
thing you can do in most cases so things
around the language
strategies and ideas for helping a young
person
be able themselves to verbalize what
they're feeling for new teachers to have
a real sense around those pastoral
responsibilities i think is absolutely
crucial
the university is offering the training
to existing teachers too many want this
bereavement support to be mandatory to
help children who seek solace find it in
those they respect
ashna harinak sky news
well let's talk to the associate
director of winston's wish susannah
phillips good morning to you i mean why
is bereavement training important when
i guess a lot of people would say and
especially teachers who are used to
clearly used to dealing with children
that perhaps they can handle it in a a
more intuitive way
uh good morning
i i think um i mean at winston's wish
we've always recognized the importance
of
the role that
teachers and other school staff members
play in supporting brief children and
we've offered training for almost 30
years in this area
we know that almost almost one child in
every class is likely to experience the
death of a parent or sibling so it's
something that teachers are very likely
to encounter throughout their careers
since the pandemic hit
we've seen an increase of about 329
in
the number of professionals
completing our training there's a real
need out there
for this knowledge and and you're right
some of it can be
intuitive but um some
research that we commissioned in 2019
from the university of cambridge really
highlighted that although schools see
this as a high priority
teachers often don't have feel that they
have the right
skill set to be able to start those
difficult conversations with children
and young people and to um to know what
to do for the best in that really tricky
time
is there a benefit to
these situations being dealt with in
school rather than being dealt with by
an outside counselor or is is this a
sense that it's how you deal with a
child on an ongoing basis
for children
grief is is very much an ongoing process
they we often talk about it as children
moving in and out of their grief so
on some days they will need a lot of
support and on other days they may be
less so and of course as they grow and
develop and move through their
school life and into their adult life
they will understand their loss in a
different way and will need a different
level of support
so as we were just hearing from louise
the holistic approach is really really
important and support for children not
only comes from family friends and their
wider community but school and when
needed organizations such as winston's
wish or or others as well are really
really important i guess there's a real
question as to what happens if a child
doesn't get the right level of support
in schools i mean presumably
it's got the potential to have a very
big impact on their education what
they're actually taking in even if they
they go to school at all
absolutely um and lots of children
receive really really good levels of
support and um and are able to process
their grief and understand what's
happened but for those children that
don't get the right support at the right
time um whether that's from school or or
from other people depending on their
needs it can lead to further
difficulties it can complicate their
grief
it can
sometimes lead to mental health
difficulties
it can impact on attendance at school
and and also attainment at school as
well
susannah we appreciate your time this
morning thank you thank you
hugely diff i mean imagine children
going through that it's
a pretty dreadful thing unless you say a
huge increase at the moment because of
the pandemic okay let's have a look at
some of the other headlines for you this
morning in one of the uk's longest
largest trade unions is warning the
government of a widespread closure of
care homes unless it scraps its no jab
no job law in england eunices says the
mandatory vaccination rule is pushing
thousands of workers to the brink of
quitting september the 16th is the
deadline for care workers to get their
first vaccination or risk losing their
jobs
labor's urging the government to appoint
a minister specifically to tackle the
issue of staff and good shortages
affecting the uk
the party says the uk's economic
recovery is at risk because of supply
chain issues
britain's energy regulator says it
should be easier and cheaper to make
large electric car charging sites help
speed up the transition to electric
vehicles offgem wants to scrap
connection charges for the sites to link
up to their local grid
time for the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
for most of us dry if a bit cloudy today
best of the sunshine in the south it
should be a bit warmer next week that's
a good news so cloudy this morning thick
enough for the odd spot of drizzle in
places
missed or fog patches in the south west
should clear throughout the course of
the morning the low cloud will thin and
break to reveal some sunny skies best of
the warm sunshine in the south and
there's a better chance of breaks in the
cloud for north sea coast compared to
what we've seen
over recent days
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so the paralympics is on its penultimate
day in tokyo and paralympics gb have
done amazingly well the metal tally tops
a hundred so an event at the olympic
park in london is marking britain's
success and highlighting the need for
long-term action for disabled people
well andrew brady is at the olympic park
for us this morning what's going on
ender
yeah a lot stephen busy busy busy here
people have been here for a couple of
hours already or this is a parasport
event you can see everyone just kind of
having a goal behind me joining in let's
bring in ellen buttrick who has just got
home from tokyo you can see around her
neck she has a gold medal in the rowing
ellen just tell me what was the whole
tokyo experience like from from your
perspective you're a rower you've
smashed everything you've come home with
gold what was it like it was a
phenomenal experience actually to be out
there and to um be there with the team
to be part of such a large motorsport
team and then and i was worried when we
got other people wouldn't be very
welcoming but the japanese public just
like embraced us so much we had people
with gb flags waving us every time we
went anywhere on the minibus and yeah
and it was just amazing to get out there
you're a visually impaired rower just
tell us a bit about your back story tell
our viewers what happened to you at the
age of 19 you're 26 now what happened
when you were 19. yeah so i was inspired
to take a run in 2012 when it was the
london olympics and then two years after
that i was diagnosed with sight
impairment called stargardt's disease
and the first thing i said was does this
mean i can row a paralympics
people think i'm making this up but it
actually was and the doctors couldn't
believe that that's why that was my only
question but i thought well what's the
what's the point in being upset about it
i can just look at the opportunity and
this is the opportunity maybe i could
road for great britain and yeah i truly
believed that i could do it and now
seven years later i've worked quite hard
and i've got there and i've got the gold
medal i'm very proud to have represented
the country
talk me through the paralympic spirit i
mean we see you guys and girls on tv
competing how much hard work has gone
into just getting there in a pandemic a
lot of hard work and it's thanks to
other support staff really and to the
national lottery especially for
supporting us in our preparation i think
a year ago when the when the games were
postponed we were worried we were like
well maybe people won't want us to go
anymore maybe we need to do other things
and then the support of them has meant
that we were able to train throughout
and be able to go to tokyo and perform
and we weren't sure like how the rest of
the world would cope and how
like we'd be in the race whether they'd
be faster than us because they'd coped a
bit better than great britain did but i
think we did very well and in their own
especially we've got two gold medals so
we're very proud of that you're based in
henley on thames in oxfordshire so maybe
a bit of rest time now and then what's
next obviously paris in three years time
yeah i do really hope to go to paris
i've got a few weeks off and then i'm
starting a masters actually in london so
um my lecturer sent me an email saying
well done and i've not even told them i
was a roar so my secret is out
so i need to get ready for that but back
to your studies yeah doctor studies but
yeah it's just been nice to be down here
today and sharing the success with the
with the young people and showing them
that they can achieve anything they want
to fantastic ellen ellen buttrick gold
medalist from paralympics gb in tokyo
just home congratulations on the goal
ellen thanks for your time today so
today is the penultimate day in tokyo it
all ends tomorrow but this has been such
a success story for paralympics gb medal
after medal and truly inspirational
stories as you can see ellen will just
leave you with a shot of a gold medal
just back from japan
oh fantastic stuff ender thank you look
at those nails as well
love it
now members of the raf's transport fleet
have been talking about the pressures
they've faced and the pride they felt in
their role evacuating thousands of
afghans from kabul as the taliban
encircled the airport they've been
describing the utter chaos on the ground
and having to dodge mortar fire people
on the runway and even a boss
our security and defense editor debra
haynes reports
it was a mission like no other thousands
of afghans escaped their country crammed
into the back of military planes
terrified tired and at times travel sick
for the air crew it was a humbling and
harrowing experience
the conditions were stark you know when
you look down the back you've got
anxious faces
you had some people who didn't think
they were going to leave afghanistan so
when they got on board the airplane the
you know the the relief
led to you know some spontaneous
reactions like you know we have one lady
who is spontaneously vomiting
continuously all over the airplane
because she'd lost her husband the day
before and she didn't know what was
going to happen c-17s like this one were
able to cram in more than 400 people at
a time strapped to the floor many of
them children
they kept flying even after a suicide
bomb attack outside kabul airport left
dozens dead
in the chaos that followed this pilot
narrowly avoided an even deadlier
disaster when a bus carrying evacuees
turned into his path on the runway as he
was trying to take off
we were about 95 knots um and they were
about a thousand feet ahead of us and we
realized that we
wouldn't have been able to reject the
take-off um because if i tried to reject
then i would have basically cleaned up
the bus and taken out the bus and
that doesn't really bear thinking about
so i had to continue the take off we got
airborne and we just missed the bus by
probably about 10 15 feet it's one of
many tales of courage starting to emerge
from the two-week evacuation mission
the royal air force's transport fleet
played a vital role in flying families
to safety
one of its aircraft tried to land on the
day after kabul fell to the taliban
the pilot saw the airfield overrun with
frantic afghans clinging to planes on
the ground
we couldn't see the runway until about
two miles out
and it it all looked clear and then
about 100 feet
a civilian vehicle drove across the
runway hotly pursued by three military
vehicles
so we had to necessitate a go around and
on the go around we could see the
airfield was completely overrun there
was people on the
taxiways people on the southern apron
the civilian airliners that were already
parked there were completely covered in
people with them on the wings clambering
all over the top of them it was just
utter chaos and did you see that
american plane that was trying to take
off that was on the ground when we were
there
we obviously didn't make it down on the
ground
another pilot revealed how the airport
had come under mortar fire a day earlier
the u.s marines in the tower called
incoming and base under attack
we had had some rounds impacting the
ground around our aircraft while we
howled short of the runway
and i recall an american helicopter
pilot calling mortars inbound and he
flew off to have a look at the
mortar tube
no british aircraft were damaged during
the evacuation mission and everyone
returned safely proud to have played
their part
albeit a role in britain's afghan
retreat
debra haynes sky news
this is sky news breakfast let's have a
look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
well most places drive a little bit
cloudy today best of the sunshine in the
south will be a bit warmer as the week
progresses so a cloudy start this
morning thick enough for a bit of
drizzle in places any sort of mist or
fog patches in the southwest should
clear as the morning moves on the low
cloud will thin and break to reveal some
sunny skies best of the warm sunshine in
the south and a better chance of breaks
in the cloud of the north sea coast
compared to recent days some scattered
light showers may develop over parts of
ireland but it should be dry just about
elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airway
time for the paper zen this morning with
the journalist padisha and the
entrepreneur kate hardcastle morning
again you two let's kick off padisha
with the front of the guardian should we
looking about
this situation in afghanistan and
particularly the impact on women and
girls
yes this is a shocking new report direct
from kabul shocking but not surprising
at all so despite the taliban saying
that they're going to respect the rights
of women and girls does anyone really
believe that does a leopard change its
spots we know from this report that
there have already been bank tellers
ordered out of their jobs women
protesters have been ordered back off
the streets they lost their jobs two
weeks ago women have already been
stopped on the street for not having a
male guardian with them the taliban have
said that oh we're going to respect
women's and girls rights but within a
framework that we're going to define
that they of course have not defined
they said that women should basically
stay at home stay off the streets stay
out of work and education and they're
citing security reasons now
the rule of the taliban is very much
within
common memory they ruled in the 90s
repressively misogynistically
oppressively and they used exactly the
same excuses then as well uh women and
girls can't be educated or work
for security reasons but don't worry
little ladies you're going to get your
rights eventually and of course that
turned out to be rubbish so the idea
that they have seized power so
shockingly so quickly and really without
a huge amount of resistance within the
last two to three weeks i remember us
talking about this just seven days ago
and they're coming in with all sorts of
claims and excuses i don't think anyone
in the international community really
believes them or trusts them at all the
problem is that if they are the ruling
government even though they've they've
gained that power by force
all the other world governments have to
have them at the table
have to listen to them and have to be
seen to be trying to enact some kind of
diplomacy with them in some kind of good
faith but of course that faith in
confidence is very thin on the ground
because of the very recent evidence of
what we've seen that they do towards
women and girls but towards the populace
generally now in that report the
guardian have seen a list of
stipulations that the taliban have
proposed for women and girls in public
life and of course no surprise it is an
extremely stringent set of rules
advising extreme and probably impossible
segregation between the sexes yeah
you understand why the foreign secretary
yesterday was calling for countries like
pakistan to try to moderate the
behaviour but it's going to be a long
process um to the independent kate
looking at supply shortages hitting of
all places ikea
do you know what stephen i actually
started to write down everything that we
have seen a shortage in
over the past few weeks that i've been
covering for obviously yourselves and
other stations and it actually turned
into the only fools and horses theme
tune you ready milkshakes chicken steaks
garden sheds and spooners beer kids toys
mattresses sausage rolls and breakfast
muffs
i reckon i've done it you haven't it's
literally
that's my courageous day
everything because of this perfect storm
we've seen an increase in demand in
certain products
we have got a shortage of drivers and
workforces we know that the brexit
element to that we also know the
sustainability element to it as well and
we've got shortages genuine shortages
for instance when we think about the
garden sheds that's linked to the timber
crisis which has been born out of yes
again shortages in terms of workforces
and pandemics but also the environmental
issues where we've seen the timber
growth not fully fully uh hit capacity
this time to meet that surge in demand
and we know that ikea certainly has been
hit with shortages for over 12 months on
certain products because many of us have
been trying to rejuvenate the home and
and create new spaces working spaces as
many of us take to working from home
more so it is going to be a challenge
because september to december is a
natural golden quarter it's a period
where we do tend to up spend on a lot of
areas and i think that we're going to
have to live with and understand that
this is going to be part of the system
until they can these organizations can
write themselves and study themselves
which is going to be down to a lot of
elements the work
situation improving finding the people
to take the jobs but also to try and
look at supply chain issues and how they
can
use other supplies do we do we need a
minister to look after this as labor
we're calling for
i think genuinely we just need somebody
who is overseeing consumerism in general
for the government okay um to the
financial times pradesh you're looking
at um
apple and and and plans just to
safeguard children on their devices
yeah you might remember about a month
ago apple announced with a huge amount
of fanfare that they were going to
introduce a new form of software to
iphones which could automatically detect
images of child sexual abuse and other
sexual abuse images based on what they
working with all the security forces and
the police internationally know to be
indicators of that kind of abuse now
that doesn't mean that there are going
to be human moderators actually looking
at all of this material they said that
this was a security feature this is
going to protect victims of these forms
of extremely horrific abuse but of
course even as i say that you can
immediately imagine the protests that
would come from civil society's civil
rights privacy campaigners what they're
saying is that this isn't safe at all
their issue is not of course with images
of child sex abuse it was saying well
hang on actually what apple is saying is
we have this new form of technology
which is really about
going into
the the photo gallery of pretty much
every iphone every smartphone every
device that you have and automatically
scrolling through that stuff anything
you want to upload download save on the
cloud whatever it is
we have eyes on it and campaign
campaigners are saying that repressive
regimes can use this they can use it
against sexual gender orientation
minorities
activists dissidents anyone who is
protesting or demonstrating so it goes
well beyond the issue of child sexual
abuse and it goes into the question of
how much do you want these tech
companies to see
of what's on your hard drive your
software
what you're sharing with your friends
and family what you're downloading if
you want to download a picture of your
favorite pop star
well
in some situations that might might be
seen as an indecent image
it's very difficult it's a it's a very
difficult one but please
something needs to be done to protect
children in all of this how you find the
balance i just don't know um we try to
encourage people to get back to work
kate the ft says we need incentives
and they're suggesting that different
workplaces are coming up with different
ideas yoga might be the thing that pulls
you back to the office are indeed a dj
playing for your return to work cash
tends to work for most people i think i
think we've also got to understand that
there is a balancing act here for
everyone that will feel the benefit and
the smaller businesses that will feel
the benefit for return to office because
obviously there is a micro environment
of sandwich shops and coffee shops and
everything else that will bolster when
people do get back to those offices i
think there are people that have made
genuine life changes here for instance
i'm going to talk as a parent a
parent's responsibility to
drop off pick up children at certain
times of day which can cause chaos if
you work in more traditional office
hours so i think people are going to be
looking back to the employees and say
well we've had a taste of flexible work
and we've proven that we've kept the
organizations going how can we create an
environment where there is balance in
all of that and i think that's what
we're going to see is the catalyst to
this shift it's going to be a shift
towards not a not return to work but
genuinely a time where we have more
balance and flexibility roles and i
sincerely think that would be a great
thing i i actually do endorse
organizations that trial in the four and
four and a half day week as well to see
if we can get better balance in there
yeah and if you never know it could
increase productivity which is a win-win
um let's have a look at the times please
bedisha why
um if you're watching this in bed this
morning you shouldn't be getting a wash
all right so apparently we're all just a
little bit too clean uh i think that we
all look pretty immaculate to not too
wiffy but of course maybe that's one of
the benefits of working from home you
don't get to smell your peers and
colleagues but this is an article about
how we could be a bit more eco-friendly
and apparently if we just use a bit less
water we're going to save the planet a
bit more so they are suggesting that you
only wash your towels once every two
weeks you have shorter showers you just
wash less generally you make sure the
tap doesn't run when you're brushing
your teeth but it also cites a couple of
interesting examples the hollywood
actress drew barrymore for example
doesn't bathe her children at weekends
so they get five out of seven nice and
clean saturday and sunday uh they can
get as grubby as they like but i'm sure
they smell hollywood los angeles peachy
at all other times so basically if
you're naturally a little bit squiffy
don't like to get under the shower head
don't worry about it you're doing good
things for the planet oh yeah
are you um can we just have a look back
at that front page again just because
what do you make of this cake we're a
similar age it's jackie weaver dressed
as wonder woman
she's brilliant isn't she she's she's
really
taken that
parish council
berating and she's made it work for her
i mean
she must be laughing at that situation
she was put under incredible pressure
and it has become a global sensation i
love it